Speaker 1: Hey, here's very interesting news. The
next Alex Jones defamation trial is starting. Now,
I know many of you are probably thinking,
David, we we just had the defamation trial.
What do you mean? Alex Jones. There was a judgment
against him for 50 million. You interviewed me. I
interviewed the attorney, Mark Bankston. Well,
remember, Mark Bankston told us that was only
the first of many trials. And the Associated
Press is now reporting trial set to begin
for Alex Jones in Sandy Hook case a month
after losing one nearly $50 million verdict.
Conspiracy theorist Alex Jones is set to go on
trial a second time for calling the Sandy Hook
Elementary School shooting a hoax and causing
several of the victim's families emotional
and psychological harm. A six member jury
with several alternates in Connecticut will
begin hearing evidence Tuesday on how much Jones
should pay the families, since he already has been
found liable for damages to them. The trial is
expected to last about four weeks. Last month,
a Texas jury ordered Jones to pay 49.3 million to
the parents of six year old Jesse Lewis, one of 26
students and teachers killed in the 2012 shooting
in Newtown, Connecticut. Jones Lawyers Jones
lawyer said an appeal is planned. This is going
to get really bad. This could be the end of Alex
Jones and Infowars. And I have to tell you, the
world would be better off if that were the case.
The Connecticut case has the potential for
an even larger award than the 50 million
because it involves three lawsuits which have been
consolidated that were filed by 15 plaintiffs,
including the relatives of nine of the victims and
a former FBI agent who responded to the shooting.
This is going to be a really big deal and the best
and most fair if we want to talk about justice,
the most just thing that can happen here. Is for
Alex Jones. They have to pay all of these victims
for what he did. And this may end Infowars. That's
true. At the same time, Alex Jones immediately
started fundraising on the last verdict,
and Roger Stone recorded videos supporting
Alex Jones fundraising on that verdict. And it's
not clear that this is it for his followers. It
actually may be motivating his followers from
some just little spits and spurts that I've been
seeing on Twitter and elsewhere. Some of the
Infowars audience is quite motivated to donate
and to buy whatever stuff Alex Jones is selling
on the basis of what they believe is a completely
unfair verdict. So I don't think it is obvious yet
that this is the end for Alex Jones and Infowars.
But Mark Bankston, the lawyer at the plaintiffs
lawyer who we interviewed not long ago,
he told me I probably don't have a defamation.
Remember, Alex Jones has attacked me. I don't
know how many of you guys remember that.
Speaker 4: Thank your lucky stars every
day. You're not David Pakman. Oh,
the bonus show where you want to make
money and everybody else that makes money
to fund themselves is bad. Pac-Man's a.
Speaker 1: Loser. Yeah. Unfortunately
that, according to Mark Bankston,
does not raise my case to the point of defamation,
but this is probably going to clean out Alex Jones
even if there are comparatively smaller verdicts,
there are so many plaintiffs in this next case,
this could be the end and we will be
covering it and we will see what happens.